un professeur de français alors je crois
que c'est vous Igor a refusé de de noter
votre dissertation en disant ou ce gamin
est un génie ou c'est un manipulateur
qui a plagié avec talent un auteur
français on va finir cette émission avec
un témoignage qui va rassembler beaucoup
de choses celui d'Igor et de Grichka
Bogdanov donc jumeaux inséparables grand
mathématicien ce qu'on sait peut-être
beaucoup moins j'imagine on vous a vu il
y a combien d'années dans X et toutes
ces émissions de science-fictions
90 s'est arrêté en 90 en fait voilà
maintenant à nouveau une émission dans
de science-fictions
j'ai oublié de préciser vous aussi
enfant dit intellectuellement précoce
surdoué et vous aussi on en parlera un
peu après donc pratiquement aucune
fréquentation vous avec les écoles donc
vous n'avez pas vraiment souffert du
regard des autres puisque vous n'avez
pratiquement jamais mis les pieds à
l'école non en fait nous avons été
des élèves incertains au sens où
effectivement nous n'avons pas été
placés par nos parents dans une école
quand nous étions petit mais c'était au
fond une vie très différente en ce sens
que nous sommes à la campagne nous avons
vécu à la campagne dans un temps
historique qui est un petit peu décalé
par rapport à disons un modèle au modèle
urbain ou effectivement on est quand
même beaucoup moins marginal donc c'est
vrai nous avons peu fréquenter l'école
et je crois que au fond le regard
pluriel que nous avons apporté l'un sur
l'autre parce que n'oublions pas que
nous sommes deux et que et si nous avons
été notre particularité
mais je crois que c'est peut-être pour
cette raison là que nous avons tout de
suite reconnu notre marginalité et que
nous en avons que nous en avons fait une
force
mais parce que vous étiez un et deux
surtout deux ou surtout a ce que vous
dites
davantage parce que je vous disiez c'est
bien d'être à deux mais est-ce que du
coup on va plus loin parce que ça peut
être un frein à un moment donné non je
crois que
le jumeau est placé dans la même
situation que n'importe quel individu
c'est à dire un moment donné il doit
définir une identité et je pense que le
jumeau il parvient peut-être plus
facilement parce qu'il était des par ce
miroir qui est en face de lui je crois
que de ce point de vue là on gagne du
temps mais c'est
vrai donc
vu le témoignage quand même certainement
bien que bon il suffit de me regarder
pour
évaluer tout de suite notre différence
parce que ce que nous sommes très très
différents surtout de la société dans
laquelle nous sommes nous sommes nés
c'est-à-dire dans le Gers en Gascogne
mais malgré cela finalement nous avons
affirmé notre différence comme un trésor
comme une force nous l'avons tout
simplement soutenu et je crois que le le
facteur d'intégration a été d'autant
plus puissant que nous étions deux à le
faire encore une fois
il y a une phrase étrange qui était dans
le dans le reportage ce que là apprenait
l'autre de savais je suppose que c'est
une métaphore quand même c'est une
métaphore absolument oui
mais en même temps
c'est juste entre nous parce que c'est
vrai un exemple de ça un exemple très
concret par exemple on s'est aperçu que
il était important d'avoir une bonne
mémoire donc on s'est dit on va
développer cette mémoire elle était bien
deux à le faire et au départ on s'est
dit on va se fixer une épreuve qui
consiste par exemple à se souvenir de 10
mots dit à la tendance de un mot et en
fait on est arrivé quand même un mot par
seconde est arrivé effectivement jusqu'à
150 mots et dont on se souvenait de
manière complètement cohérente et sans
la moindre erreur au bout de au bout de
trois mois donc
en fait on était deux et c'était bien un
entraînement de l'esprit c'est là où je
rejoins d'ailleurs le professeur
jacquard c'est qu'effectivement nous
avons tous la possibilité
détendre des dons qui sont latins ou qui
sont manifestes mais on peut à tout âge
à tout instant étendre son espace de
d'aptitude et c'est ce que nous avons
fait parfois au fond au fond le message
que des livres jusqu'à c'est tout
simplement celui-ci c'est que nous
sommes tous des surdoués d'une manière
ou d'une autre et que nous avons tous
pour mission d'une certaine manière
d'exprimer c'est dans la ça peut être le
calcul mais ça peut être tout à fait
autre chose comme disait Jérôme
finalement on peut s'exprimer dans
n'importe quel domaine au fond quand on
est on a pour mission d'une certaine
manière on est confronté à un espèce de
de gigantesque mystère qui est celui
dans notre situation au monde et donc
nous avons pour mission de décoder cette
espèce de grand mystère cosmique dans
lequel nous avons été plongés sans le
sans le vouloir sans l'avoir demandé et
cette cette mission qui a aussi qui est
aussi associée à
cet extraordinaire miracle qui consiste
à ce que chacun de nous
résume d'une certaine manière toute
l'histoire de l'humanité de la vie alors
pourquoi l'un et l'autre toujours
fasciné par depuis enfant par la
science-fiction parce que la
science-fiction c'est une espèce de jeu
sur sur le réel et c'est finalement
jouer donc avec des possibles et la
science ne fait pas autre chose
c'est-à-dire que la science lorsqu'elle
produit des hypothèses et en cela donc
le professeur jacquard ne me contera pas
c'est une une manière d'évaluer une
possibilité
sur le réel et donc la science-fiction
lorsqu'elle nous parle par exemple
d'hypothèse aussi
lointaine que l'une les univers
parallèles ou le voyage dans le temps
par exemple constitue un terrain
d'exercice pour l'imaginaire qui est
tout à fait fascinant mais est-ce que à
l'inverse ça ne vous a pas apporté du
discrédit le fait de justement
mathématicien qui qui avant tout était
médiatisé connu par la science-fiction
est-ce que ça pu jeter une ombre aussi
Igor Grichka il y a toujours des
questions de frontières qui
effectivement vous avez franchi que
d'autres une étude ne franchissent pas
il est tout à fait clair que
dans un dans un contexte
français ou nous vivons aujourd'hui
c'est moins vrai aux États-Unis mais
c'est vrai en France il y a des
catégories rigides effectivement il y a
des contextes comme ça de d'exclusion
des principes d'exclusion de l'un et de
l'autre d'un côté il y a l'imaginaire de
l'autre il y a des méthodologies
scientifiques et le réel et il est
difficile de de faire de passage de l'un
à l'autre en toute impunité vis-à-vis de
du monde extérieur l'imaginaire est une
ressource et il faut la prendre comme
tel et on ne fait rien je crois de
profondément innovant et créatif si on
se coupe de cette ressource là et c'est
une sensibilité un mode créatif en
quelque sorte qu'il faut absolument
utiliser
en mathématiques je pensais que c'était
un truc absolument impossible et puis en
travaillant je me suis aperçu que on
peut être créatif mais dans tous les
domaines créatifs ça veut pas être dire
être artiste on peut être créatif en
maths on peut être créatif en business
on peut être créatif en littérature on
peut être on peut être épanoui quoi tout
simplement je trouve formidable de voir
des gens qui s'éclatent en faisant des
maths
positif
qui était compliqué j'imagine pour vous
tous les maths la physique
également votre pied avec les
physiques
c'est comme ça qu'on avait formé les
profs de maths
je vous jure que les mathématiques
c'était un enfer
et pour il y a aucun tapis rose
magnifique justement à l'âge de par
exemple de Claire peut-être un petit peu
de non je crois qu'il avait 10 ans donc
il avait un an de moins le fameux gosse
dont on a parlé tout à l'heure il y a
plusieurs reprises avec certaines
bien sûr donc qui est sur la chaussette
exactement à gauche c'est un personnage
dont on parle beaucoup aujourd'hui et
qui a fait effectivement progresser
l'horizon des connaissances techniques
la technologie les mettre des
mathématiques mais qui est né en 1777
donc il y a déjà assez longtemps et qui
à l'âge de 9 ans et demi très exactement
se trouve soumis par son instituteur
donc là-bas en Allemagne Carl Friedrich
Go c'était allemand
à la question suivante prenez une
feuille de papier dis donc l'instituteur
et vous allez écrire tous les chiffres
de 1 à 100 1 2 3 4 5 etc et puis
maintenant vous allez les additionner
vous allez additionner dans tous les
chiffres de 1 à 100 quel est le résultat
demande le l'instituteur et à ce
moment-là la classe commence
effectivement méthodiquement à
additionner 1 + 2 = 3 + 3 = 6 et ainsi
de suite
20 secondes après gauche arrive en
donnant au professeur le résultat et il
dit ça fait
500050 comment est-ce qu'il est arrivé à
ce résultat il y a trois façons d'y
parvenir la première c'est celle que
effectivement la classe suivait un plus
deux plus trois etc la seconde c'est
d'appliquer une forme de mathématique il
y en a une haine le facteur de N+1
divisé par 2 et on a effectivement
des chiffres donc de 1 à 100 tous les
nombres
et on dit on va créer des paires on dit
1 + 100 ça fait combien
ça fait bon et ensuite 99 + 2 ça fait
combien voilà 98 + 3
jusqu'à ce qu'on arrive à 50 c'est dire
50 paires
ce qui nous donne effectivement 550
à tout d'un coup un socratif phénoménal
parce qu'il dit mais c'est comme ça que
ça marche comment instituteur a-t-il
accepté cette cette réponse
il a dit bon ça c'est il y a un vrai
problème il est allé voir le père de
Frédéric goss qui était donc comptable
et le père lui a dit écoutez il y a rien
étonnant à ça en fait mon fils a pris
raconté bien avant de parler et
heureusement il y avait
madame mais il y avait pas de
psychologue à l'époque
je voudrais revenir juste sur un petit
point parce qu'on a l'impression que
vous il n'y a pas eu de problème et tout
mais quand vous étiez quand vous étiez
je vous aviez je crois 13 ans l'une des
rares fois où vous êtes retrouvés sur
les bandes du lycée un professeur de
français alors je crois que c'est vous
Igor refusé de de noter votre
dissertation en disant ou ce gamin est
un génie ou c'est un manipulateur qui a
plagié avec talent un auteur français
vous vous souvenez est-ce que ça fait
partie du drame des des jeux est-ce
qu'il y avait des choses que vous aviez
réécrites dont vous souveniez où c'était
purement ça sortait de votre temps ça
sortait totalement de de totalement de
ma tête c'est tout simple c'est tout
simple Grishka et moi nous avons parlé
pour vraiment beaucoup plus tôt que les
autres parce que nous étions dans la
même berceau que nous aurons donc été
verbalisé très très vite et que
l'expérience du langage nous a été
vraiment très très familière très tôt et
donc par la suite nous avons continué à
parler à manipuler cette espèce de grand
trésor de langue comme ça
une espèce de de sémiologie un petit peu
plus réelle qui nous a fait connaître
peut-être plus vite disons quantité de
livres et donc accumuler dans notre
mémoire des sensations de lecture des
mondes que j'avais évidemment pas
beaucoup de mal et j'avais pas tellement
de mérites au fond à retranscrire sous
une forme comme ça dans une rédaction et
comme encore une fois j'ai pris ça comme
un compliment
un peu plus tard je crois que c'est vous
Grichka donc un professeur s'est en
terminale a dit à votre grand-mère quand
Grichka prend la parole il se prend pour
Dieu vous souvenez
pas du tout pris pour un compliment
parce que c'était absolument pas vrai et
je n'ai pas du tout intégré la raison
pour laquelle il l'a dit si ce n'est que
il y a probablement eu un moment c'est
vrai une certaine un caractère peut-être
un peu directorial mais que appliquez
pas aux autres mais à moi-même à partir
de là je me suis quand même remise en
cause
il y a toujours quand même des aspects
positifs à ce genre de choses et je me
suis dit à partir de l'instant où il y a
une perception qui intervient et qui
vous classe dans un ordre comme ça un
peu dictateur
qui ne sont pas du tout celles que l'on
que l'on que l'on souhaite faire passer
alors probablement qu'il faut modifier
certaines choses vous savez pourquoi
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui a
été qui a été dit quand Charlie et Hugo
parler professeur jacquard leur disait
il faut douter on a l'impression que
vous avez vous affirmer des choses j'ai
le sentiment c'est important maintenant
que vous parliez vous des adolescents de
l'adolescents que vous avez été ou du
petit garçon en fait des personnages
habités par un principe d'incertitude
qui fait que nous sommes devenus au sens
bernisien mais tous les
nous sommes très très des sujets des
sujets incertain
u le physique un certain aussi
vous avez quand même que que je rajoute
autre chose
quand même vous voulez vous voulez cette
différence cette différence quand même
juste pour finir cette différence
physique vous la travaillez aussi pour
être comme ça
pour planer sur
entre différents mondes
c'est une donnée fondamentale finalement
de de qui n'est pas seulement la nôtre
mais que je crois que tout le monde
devrait essayer de d'acquérir j'ai parlé
de la vie multiple tout à l'heure
lorsque nous avons une existence
publique si on peut dire à travers tant
x c'était tiers et puis projet Express
aujourd'hui à la télévision sur une
émission de science-fiction nous sommes
perçus comme les Bogdanov face à la
science-fiction et disons à des
j'allais dire des rêves de papoter c'est
un petit peu ça quand même et puis mais
par ailleurs quand nous publions un
papier ce que personne ne sait dans
Annales of physique ou physique letters
ou des revues comme ça
Jérôme là
qui s'exprime et au fond le flou ne
vient pas de la précision extrême qu'on
apporte un projet extrême ou à telle
équation dans le papier pour visiteurs
mais du rapprochement des deux c'est à
dire au fond c'est le flou vient de là
et il est évidemment dans la dans dans
le regard de l'autre bien sûr je
laisserai la parole à Albert Jacquard
pour la conclusion parce que je vous
vois écouter quand même
Igor et Grichka Bogdanov qu'on appelle
les frères
voilà avec beaucoup d'interrogations
est-ce que vous êtes confrontés à
l'énigme une dernière énigme celle des
jumeaux intermédiaire
[Rires]
on le voit d'ailleurs dans le reportage
un des surdoués des sous-doués etc etc
qu'est-ce que vous dites en les écoutant
de l'année de l'autre tu as les frères
beau jour par leurs parents le même jour
pour tous les deux et puis ils ont eu
une aventure et il se trouve que cette
aventure ses aventures parce que c'est
quand même deux aventures et bien elles
ont se sont entrelacés et quand même
mais vous n'êtes pas le frère Bogdanov
en un seul morceau vous êtes les
individus divers entre la
s’émerveilleusement et c'est vrai que
c'est passionnant à voir et à écouter
c'est pourquoi j'ai j'ai été interpellé
par cette phrase ce que l'un prenait
autre le savait bien sûr ça dépendra ça
n'est pas vrai mais c'est joliment dit
mais c'est vrai on pourrait finir
là-dessus non de manière générale ce que
là à prendre l'autre le sait non dans la
vie
quelque part découvre je pourrais un
jour en profiter et c'est ça qui est
merveilleux et ça ça avait été dit je
crois pas Léonard de Vinci déjà je n'ai
pas qu'un cerveau il aurait dit
aujourd'hui j'en ai fait Miller
exactement on va finir là dessus je vous
remercie tous d'avoir accepté que l'on
pénètre un peu dans vos univers
tellement différent tellement multiples
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]